this is going to be a fun show Mark has
been back there practicing his skits all
day I walked past the dressing room Mark
was staring into the mirror like Natalie
Bourbon and Black Swan for an hour
please welcome Mark Ellis
[Applause]
thank you Los Angeles how's everybody
doing
oh it is so good to be here we have a
lot to get through I have to start with
this I know a lot of you came out here
for a great stand-up show but some of
you came here just to make sure I was in
fact still alive
um and this is sort of my fault and I
need to apologize for it because I was
excited about the show as we're taping
it it's Saturday night this past
Wednesday I got a flyer and I was like
oh I know I'll post this flyer on social
media so people know about the show I
posted the picture and it's a good
picture of me I thought
it's me on stage microphone smiling
Whimsical look in my eye you can tell
this boy's dream is coming true
but the problem was it was a black and
white photo
already some fans of mine started to get
nervous
they're like oh no what happened to the
boy with the dream
it's a black and white photo nobody ever
does that and then the mistake was
compounded because there was like a
bluish Hue over my head
I look like a force ghost in retrospect
and then it said Mark Ellis live special
taping but it wasn't the letters like
live special taping it was way at the
bottom live special taping
and the kind of fun it was can only be
described as Church pamphlet cursive
so I posted it thinking all right let's
see how it goes an hour later I checked
Instagram over a thousand likes and I'm
like somebody's selling out some shows
this weekend
and then I saw the comments top comment
over a hundred likes on it what the [__]
dude are you dead
all lower case no punctuation
and it's very out of character for my
mom to use that kind of language
so I'm here tonight to entertain you but
also to let everybody know that I'm
alive I am well I am in my adopted home
of Southern California
we have a packed house here and I'm so
glad you all showed up I really am
because I need a theater full of people
to get out of the house
it's a rough pandemic for me man because
I'm an optimist
and I think a lot of optimists had a
really tough time
the last couple years if you're in this
room and you see the glass is half full
if you see the covet test is half
negative
pandemic started all of us optimists
were like we got this
Humanity can do this let's get this over
with we've walked in there we're like we
can all wear masks for two weeks okay
we'll mask up 14 days day 15. we'll all
go outside rip our masks off in unison
breathe the fresh air throw it in the
air like it's a high school graduation
ceremony
except we didn't graduate did we no
America we were the kid that got held
back
and it was a tough one for me personally
because when the pandemic started I was
in my 30s
[Laughter]
I marched into that thing a confident
healthy energetic 30-something cuts of
me coming out a tired grizzled broken
40-something what's a tick tock
who names the stallion Meg where are my
Wednesday pills
I was like a wolf that had been hunting
in the wild then it got domesticated for
a couple years and now I'm on the tundra
and I can't hunt anymore
I'm just out there Running With The Pack
guys Postmates isn't going to be here
for another eight hours so
we all went a little minimalist right we
all got a little isolated the last
couple years everybody got a new hobby
everybody got a new hobby we've got some
bread people here
yes you know who got crazies the air
fryer Folk
yeah some of you [__] with air fryers
y'all started out conservative right you
got the air fryer the first week you
plug it in all right don't make any
sudden movements
and what was your first meal with the
airfry let's just do one Bagel bite get
down get down
and then week two everybody thought they
were Guy Fieri
we got a whole cow we're gonna see if we
can fit it into this one air fryer
I got a new hobby too I started doing
drugs
thank you
you saw my last special dog step brother
you know I don't do the drugs and uh
well that's in the past
oh what they were talking about in high
school not only am I having fun I think
I'm hooked
good time I like the Edibles I like the
weed it helps me sleep helps me relax
takes the edge off the blow
not for me too is that I'm old enough to
remember when it was illegal so now when
I go to a dispensary I still feel like
I'm doing something a little naughty
you know I tiptoe in
anything the cops are here there's a
security guard at every dispensary
I go to this place in the valley called
ice cream but the cream is spelled with
a K so you know that in ice cream in my
bag
and I acknowledge I started way too late
I'm way too late in the game like drugs
it's like skiing or golf if you want to
get good you got to start when you're a
little kid right
because nobody has good drug stories my
age that happens when you're young right
like how old were you your first drug
16. okay it was it the wheat or did you
just slam the H right in your toes what
was the
you can tell I'm new because I still
call it the wheat like
I go to an ice cream you sell doobies
here is that a thing
yeah I uh I I like I'm jealous of that
because like you're 16 you get high you
probably had fun man we got cut class
and then we woke up in a dumpster like
it's a funny story
what's a good drugstore in your 40s man
I got so high last night I lost my
family
yeah me and the boys we got baked over
the weekend and now we live in Extended
Stay America so I don't know how
and I'll still make rookie mistakes with
it too I uh I like to usually my routine
is I'll do my shows at night and then
I'll do an edible when I get home watch
my stories and go to bed
right a couple weeks ago I didn't have
any shows it was a Tuesday night it was
like 6 30 and I'm like I think it's
enough
I think I've waited long enough to get
the edible in here so I crank it into my
gullet and I start feeling it then I
realize oh no Mark didn't eat dinner yet
that's mistake number one then I uh made
another one by deciding it was a good
time to go to the grocery store
see all you professionals are like dude
you cannot be doing this to me right now
it gets worse so when I'm sober I shop
at Whole Foods where are my Whole Foods
people at
there you go clap if you think you're
better than everybody that's
been me for the better part of the last
decade as I go to Whole Foods but on
this particular night I got high and I
was like I think it's time to go back to
Ralphs
yep Ralph's for my East Coast friends
it's like the Food Lion or the Wegmans
up in the Pacific Northwest it's like
the QFC it's the normal grocery store
but I've been going to Whole Foods
forever so then I got high and went back
to Ralph's and it was like I was
skipping into Willy Wonka's chocolate
factory
oh it was beautiful everything that I
remember was there the snacks the
desserts deodorant that actually works
it's an amazing place
as soon as I walked into this land of
Miracles I grabbed a balloon it wasn't
my birthday I just wanted the balloon
and then I hit aisle six
and aisle six for you Ralph's regulars
you know that's the cereal aisle
and to me that night that was the
Asgardian bridge to Valhalla
I remember all the cereals Tony the
Tiger waving me back we missed you bud
because Whole Foods they don't have a
cereal aisle if you're lucky they have a
lady handing granola on the way out
they have one sad Shelf with a couple
different cereals the best stuff at
Whole Foods is this stuff called
Heritage crunch
sounds like it's from the Revolutionary
War
Heritage crunch Heritage is another word
for old
I'm not starting a new day with old
crunch
I don't want to eat Heritage crunch I'd
like to speak to the captain of crunch
if I may
Heritage crunch sounds like Captain
crunch's racist grandfather
thank you
after you boys are done playing Pirates
I got this flag I want to show you in my
study come here
[Applause]
and all this uh marijuana users got some
good news recently President Biden he uh
he repealed that anybody who ever had a
simple possession that's gone you're
pardoned you're good to go which is good
news
good news
um I don't necessarily want Biden
himself doing uh the drugs
um
I love that every time there's an
election cycle every time we're looking
at who the new president could be the
media always loves asking that question
have you ever gotten high you ever
smoked weed I remember the first time I
saw it was when I was a kid and they
asked Clinton and Clinton was like I
don't know maybe
[Laughter]
come on back to my room
fine and then they asked George W bush
the question and he did not understand
it and
Obama was the first one Obama was the
first one who just flat out admitted and
he shocked everybody so have you ever
smoked pot and he was like ah yeah
really fun
so Obama admitted he smoked weed Trump
claimed he never did and I don't know if
y'all notice slight difference in
temperament
no I'm not saying Trump doesn't do drugs
but if he does wheat is not the one he's
been enjoying
and you could tell as the presidency
started to unravel right they're
supposed to be like a peaceful
transition of power there's supposed to
be a nice sit down between the sitting
president and the incoming president and
it works like a relay race right like
the president has the Baton they hand it
to the next one so here comes Donnie
around the corner and he's about to hand
the Baton to Joe and he's like [__] you
go get it
[Applause]
one of the last things Trump did when he
when he was like Air Force One out you
know you know where we're going nowhere
they didn't have a destination he just
wanted to be in the big plan one more
time
so my theory is they got in the plane
they did a few laps around DC they did a
mountain of Coke
probably came up with a great idea for a
fusion restaurant
and then the plane lands and the last
thing Trump did before he de-planned Air
Force One for the very last time I think
Trump took an upper decker in the
bathroom
now some of you in this crowd may be too
classy to know what an upper decker is
luckily for you I went to college in
North Carolina
so in upper decker is where you poop not
in the toilet but you take the lid off
the back you poop in there put the
toilet lid back on nobody knows where
the smell is coming from
and I don't think the Biden
Administration has found it yet
and that's why Biden trips every time he
goes up the stairs the Air Force One
[Applause]
I feel so bad for
them impressed at the athleticism
because he falls up
I don't know which pill in The Matrix he
took but he just keeps going he's like a
reverse Slinky it's an incredible thing
and wheat isn't even really the cool
drug for the kids for the the Gen Z's
the Millennials y'all like your shrooms
now
we've got shroom people they have their
fun little terms like micro dosing
like oh no I'm micro dosing like it's
not like you're doing drugs still
micro dosing it's like I'm not an
alcoholic it's a coronita just a tiny
little one
shrimps shrimps is what happens when you
give disposable income to a generation
raised on Mario Kart
been taught these shrooms were good for
you your whole life
and I've eaten my errors before that
like I my Mario didn't have a vehicle
if you were lucky you had a dinosaur
give you a lift in like one level
but I go all the way back to the
original Super Mario Brothers which was
the best because it was so easy they
would just aim you in One Direction and
this is your whole video game right here
if you ran too far this way you can't
even go back that way get your fat ass
to the castle
premise of Super Mario Brothers a king's
daughter gets kidnapped by a giant
dragon
and he sends Two Italian plumbers to go
rescue
the king got all his hands together he's
like all right we need to get my little
girl back I do not want to spend a lot
of money ideas
they're like well Navy Seals that's
expensive Marines are pretty costly one
guy races saying hey you remember those
two guys that fixed the toilet last week
yeah the one found the upper decker we
had no idea what that smell was
[Music]
I'm a big I'm a big sports fan I love
the NFL I uh I played college football
on Xbox and um
had to retire concussions you know how
it goes
it's been tougher to play like like
Madden is so complex now Madden you can
actually make yourself into an NFL
player
you can make me
into an NFL athlete which is actually
easier than going to the gym
because like I could be sore tomorrow or
I can win the Super Bowl right now
and and it's weird being a sports fan my
age because I'm 42 years old and you
realize that now every ad is targeted
right at you everyone every time I watch
a game every time I listen to Sports
Talk Radio every ad starts the same way
are you past your Prime
[Laughter]
do not have the energy you used to I
think it's me they're talking to
are you a little [__] Mark who sang
that
trying to hop us up on energy boys now
I'm nervous every time I go work out
every time I go to the driving range I'm
worried Doug floating Frank Thomas are
gonna jump out of the bushes throw some
pills at me
don't take the bait man I'm too old to
have energy energy is going to get me
arrested
go out after the show you're going to
see a bunch of guys in their 20s and
they have way too much energy they're
like oh it's Saturday I gotta [__]
something or fight something I don't
know what it's gonna be
and I was like that when I was in my 20s
I wanted to date every woman I saw right
same thing in my 30s in my 40s I want to
sleep
that's it and energy that's gonna [__]
up my nap
I love naps man I took it I took the 5
p.m today
I refer to naps like it's a train
schedule
I took the 5 p.m backstage and that's my
favorite one because the 5 p.m is where
you go to bed and it's light out and
then you wake up and it's dark and
you're like what the [__] happened where
am I
like I thought about this I love sleep
so much I no longer fear death
it's just a good snooze
so when you're at my funeral we'll use
the picture I posted
[Applause]
but don't if you get to eulogize me
don't do the the normal stuff don't say
Mark died doing what he loved no say
Mark's dead and now he's doing what he
loves
I try to make it to the gym when I can I
um I have a personal trainer because I
work in entertainment and that's the law
seriously all you dreamers out there
thinking about moving to La here's how
it works you drive out to California
they stop you at the border you
surrender all your fruits and vegetables
and they hand you a personal trainer
sir you got to give us those avocados
and this is Cricket your trainer enjoy
they're just so optimistic and positive
all the time like I go to the gym and
they're like all right Mark today's leg
day I'm like uh leg day how do you think
I got in here we are good on the legs
they demo the movements for you which is
a little intimidating because they show
you how to do it properly and then I
have to follow that and they're like
Mark here's how you do a deadlift and
I'm like thinking that's how a 28 year
old does a deadlift
I'm 42. my deadlift is call two of my
friends
hey you [__] want free pizza help me
move this couch get over here
it's still going better than
out here I didn't know what to do I
joined a gym called 24 Hour Fitness
and it sounds like a good premise right
it's open all day all night problem was
back then I was chubby I was robust I
was portly I'm trying to think of other
phrases that aren't the f word
we're not supposed to say the thing I
called Mario and Luigi I'm not supposed
to say that
okay I can say the word fat most of my
best friends are fat so
that was an accurate description of me
at the time when I was out here and if
you're in my situation 24-Hour Fitness
is tough there's never a good hour to go
you can either go in the middle of the
night when it's just you and some
nutcase wearing a Spider-Man costume
right next to you
put down the camera Peter I get it
or you can go in the middle of the day
which is the worst time to go if you're
overweight because it's always the good
looking athletic the winners in life on
the treadmills and then there's just a
line of chubby people like we would have
been in at TGI Fridays by now what's the
I'm sorry but I think if you're the
biggest one at the gym you can go up to
anybody uh yeah excuse me
you're training for a triathlon that's
cute last night I got drunk and ate a
birthday cake by myself
your five percent body fat I'm five
percent dominoes off you go
yeah that's the phrase man past your
Prime and I'm not ready to admit that
I'm past my Prime yet I will say this is
as good as it's gonna get so
and you ladies thinking about it
tonight's the night
and every time I like I'm talking to a
girl who's younger than me I feel
desperate stockbroker
you're trying to talk her into a stock
that I know is [__]
because guys when you're in your 20s in
investment terms you're like gold you're
silver you're precious metals You're
Gonna Last Forever once you hit 40 your
cryptocurrency
you know like I look good tonight it
could all be gone tomorrow
and you have to make do with what you
have we have pills for some stuff we
have surgeries for other things but
nothing's going to make these hands any
bigger
I don't care who you voted for these are
Trump hands we can all admit that right
just tiny little grabbing any [__]
power documents before you leave office
[Applause]
and if you look at it throughout the
history of time every dictator had tiny
little hands that's why they had to be a
dictator every cult leader tiny hands
every one of them Jonestown Nexium
Peloton they all have tiny little hands
just begging you to stay with them on
this journey
keep pedaling the bike mark
hands are going to stay this size feet
aren't going to grow anymore I'll be
honest once you're in a certain age this
doesn't work as well
I'm not ashamed to admit it my
reproductive area it's about as
effective as the Johnson and Johnson
vaccine
[Applause]
it's probably gonna be okay let's
I got a 66 completion percentage let's
go in the bedroom
that was the thing that bothered me is
like I was all for a vaccine I wanted a
vaccine but the way we rolled it out
this kind of thought was dumb because
like people think that Americans want
free we don't we don't want anything
free we say we do I want free health
care then you got free healthcare I
don't trust this [__] anymore
we want exclusive
okay we don't want free we want
exclusive think about it you came to the
show tonight if everybody got a free
t-shirt you'd be like look at this cheap
piece of [__]
but I could take this whole crowd to a
basketball game and the mascot comes out
with the T-shirt cannon you're losing
your goddamn Minds give me the shirt
give me the show
so next time there's a pandemic I want a
vaccine don't get me wrong I want there
to be a vaccine but just don't announce
it because we can't handle it it's going
to get politicized it's going to get
divisive make the vaccine and just put
it in McNuggets
yeah you vaccinated McNuggets the whole
pandemic's gonna be over in three weeks
and then when it's time for our booster
shot the McRib is back for a limited
time only
I thought you retired it well monkey pox
brought it out of retirement baby
you know anti-vaxxers would find out
though they find out we're spiking the
McNuggets with medicine
maybe protesting outside Mickey D's you
didn't tell us what you're putting in
the McNuggets
and McDonald's is like we've never told
you
[Applause]
think the clown tells us what he's doing
up there we don't know
go to McDonald's after the show ask them
what's in a Quarter Pounder they're like
oh there's some brown
um
it's a little thing of orange I think
they always have their excuses you know
they're conspiracy theories some people
thought they get microchipped
when they got the vaccine so they
thought they were getting microchipped
at Walgreens
that's where we're keeping them really
that's where the government's storing
the microchips
at Walgreens right next to the
self-checkout that doesn't work for more
than 10 consecutive minutes
[Applause]
you are right now you're safe
they always have the same reasoning like
I don't want the government to know what
I'm doing or where I'm going three hours
later we tell them we're all Buffalo
Wild Wings get in here selfie
[Applause]
I was thinking about this a lot and I I
don't think it'd be the worst thing if
we microchipped Humanity
okay I don't think it'd be the worst
thing just go with me on this because
currently on Earth we have one species
that we regularly microchip and dogs
look pretty happy
I have a dog she was better than anybody
in this room
she gets to sleep all the time she gets
to eat more she gets the whole food [__]
she gets to go outside she gets to take
a [__] outside
the smile on this young boy's face when
I said that
I could do that yeah
the microchips on yes you too
don't you just want to try that freedom
once
she'll write out there on Wilshire
Boulevard just drop trial and nobody
gets mad at you like oh this is great
they don't get mad at you they get mad
at you for not picking it up how great
would that be
oh he's so cute bring a bag [__]
I did that joke in New York and uh this
woman yelled out in the back what about
cats
I'm like yeah I know we microchip cats I
guess and cats are I don't consider them
pets they're more like in-laws
you know like they they kind of show up
and they just don't really leave and
there's technically love there but it's
they're just really judging you
feed them once they just stay
I don't know I did have like I was
suspicious of the vaccine recently
because I don't know if anybody else is
going through this I can't remember [__]
like my memory is awful and it's the
kind of memory loss where if you're
looking for your keys then you're like
oh I was holding my keys the whole time
they're like I can't find my sunglasses
they're on my head or how long I've been
driving this car for this is not good
and every time that happens to me my
knee-jerk reaction is that's the vaccine
never once did I consider it might be
due to the fact that I don't do drugs
every night of my life
that never came up in the thought
process
couple Edibles some beers every night I
don't know why my brain's foggy
it's got to be that one shot of medicine
I got eight months ago
but I did discover a hidden benefit to
marijuana a hidden power to marijuana is
that now documentaries last forever
because I'll put on a documentary high
I'll watch 20 minutes fall asleep the
next night I go to pick it up and I'm
like I don't remember the last 15
minutes of what I watched last night
I think it's time to go back to one part
documentaries
they're getting a little too beefy not
every story needs 10 parts
I watched a 13-part documentary on
whether a woman fell down the stairs or
not
that's the whole documentary
wasn't a famous athlete or an
international conflict we were just
figuring out is she clumsy or did she
marry the wrong guy I don't know
and I was riveted I was like did she
fall was she pushed why do I care about
this person
when I was a kid I watched a documentary
on the formation of the universe one
hour
[Applause]
with commercials
now there is some subject matter that
dictates you need a longer time to tell
the story My Favorite documentary of all
time Ken Burns is the Civil War
or else we'll call it in 10 years Civil
War won
I hope we can all laugh about that in a
decade but I don't know
I'm fascinated by the Civil War I grew
up on a lot of those battlefields and it
goes through everything the Civil War
documentary is comprehensive you get the
battle with Fort Sumter the surrendered
Appomattox Captain America and Iron Man
duking it out
but the most fascinating part of it to
me is the assassination of Abraham
Lincoln so as The Story Goes Abraham and
Mary Todd they saw play that night at
Ford's Theater after a long day of
vampire hunting
can anybody name what play they were at
oh
I have the best goddamn fans in the
world
they're like all right we can't just
yell that we'll raise our hand and hope
he calls on us
all right you guy that really wants to
take a [__] outside what do you uh
what's
our American cousin uh we were looking
for Jersey Boys he was actually saying
Jersey Boys
no you're right it was our American
cousin and that you can still go see
Ford's Theater I grew up in DC you still
go to Ford's Theater see the balcony you
can see next door where John Wilkes
Booth snuck in It's A Hard Rock Cafe
right so John Wilkes Booth had a big
bowl of Heritage Crunch and then he
starts
needling into the Hard Rock Cafe it's a
genius plot because nobody's going to
hear a gunshot when we're rocking out to
Def Leppard
so Booth jumps in he caps Lincoln and he
was a known actor at the time and you
thought [__] could get canceled today
he shot the president and then being the
you know the thespian he is he made a
show he jumped on stage broke his leg in
the process but landed and he said to
the crowd six semper tyrannus
which is Latin for thus to all tyrants
but I have a feeling not a lot of people
in here knew that
and it's nothing against y'all I didn't
know it either but man crowds were
educated in the 1860s
this guy just shot the president of the
United States he jumps on stage says
[__] in Latin and they're all like wow
okay I get it
the other actors were on stage like do I
yes and this I don't know
I mean put that in context today if
somebody broke in here and they shot me
in the back of the head and said six
separate tyrannus the cops would be
interviewing y'all after the show
did he say anything I think he said
something about antifa I I really don't
you're a good crowd we can talk about
abortion
um
I don't want to do it either but I'm a
white man it's my job to tell you ladies
how to feel about your bodies
I don't have a uterus here's what to do
with yours
those who can't do teach
[Applause]
you know what I'll back up so
a little while ago my Twitter account
got hacked
um my Twitter account got hacked and
everybody in this crowd knows Twitter if
you're watching this a few months later
Twitter was an app on your phone
[Applause]
[Music]
where you could get some information and
you could realize that the thing you've
loved your whole life is actually stupid
and so my Twitter account got hacked and
I verified how the blue check mark
before the bird had a yard sale I had
the verified
and so it's my blue check mark it's my
name it's my picture but I couldn't get
in there it was a scam and the scam
posted from my account which people
trust hey guys I know times are tough
right now but I'm selling PlayStation 5s
for 50 bucks
[Applause]
and I'm donating all the proceeds to
charity
and this happened to be the day
when Roe v Wade was being overturned and
so on my timeline a lot of women I
follow a lot of women I admire were
saying very important things one of the
prevalent themes of that day was where
are all the men right now
[Applause]
we need men to speak up men are being
awfully silent Here Comes Mark who wants
a PlayStation 5 for 50 bucks
[Applause]
[Music]
the skirts are dealing with something
come on boys let's play video games
and for the record I am pro-choice I
think that's a pretty easy
way to go about it you're a woman you're
pregnant it's your decision I will also
say that if I'm the one that got you
pregnant I know which team I'm rooting
for
but it's not my call that's a problem
men always want to get involved we look
at everything in terms of competition in
terms of Athletics so we want to be on
the playing surface but in this
particular ball game we're not on the
playing surface we're in the rafters
just cheering for our side you know good
luck honey we don't want it
and I just hate anytime you have a
debate about modern science some [__]
has to say well let's see what the Bible
has to say about this and it's like oh
God here we go and like I have nothing I
have a lot against the Bible I shouldn't
say that I
look I think the Bible's fine I think
it's a great prequel to Lord of the
Rings here's the problem
I just hate when religion messes with
science because it's never the other way
around right science never messes with
religion nobody's ever been caught
sneaking a microscope into church
I never hear a priest make a baptism
like I now baptize you in two parts
hydrogen one part oxygen
as the other way around and I hate when
religion messes with chicken restaurants
[Applause]
you all know exactly the one I'm talking
about
because it's Saturday night you got
about an hour to get there
[Applause]
Chick-fil-A closes on Sundays which
makes no sense as a business because
it's not going to make any of us more
religious
I know I'm not the only idiot that is
rolled up to a Chick-fil-A on a Sunday
hung over like oh right God damn it
he's going to Chick-fil-A on a Sunday
see that they're close and be like oh
well I guess we'll go worship
I don't need waffle fries I just need
one way from some grape juice that'll
tide me over
and Chick-fil-A's just closed on Sunday
that place looks like it hasn't been
open in a hundred years
it's a horror movie there's like
tumbleweeds in the parking lot Windows
shot out old guy in a rocking chair we
don't get many visitors no more
and I'm not saying the Bible can't teach
us some stuff about Modern Life for
instance the very first Karen is in the
Bible
yeah very first book The Book of Genesis
you got Adam and you got Eve and God
said okay Adam Eve here's the deal you
can do whatever you want in Paradise
there's just this one tree I don't want
you to touch cool and Adam's like got it
and Eve was like I'd like to speak to a
manager
I just feel like if you're gonna make a
law that governs women's bodies based on
belief it needs to be the belief that
every woman subscribes to so make
abortion legal only when Mercury is in
retrograde
[Applause]
foreign
I might have had one of my female
friends write that joke I don't know
like I don't believe in that [__] but I
did wait until it was out of retrograde
to tape my special so
now the real problem I have is uh is the
guys in the room any guys who are
anti-abortion I don't understand that if
you're a dude in this room and you're
anti-abortion you need to go to
Disneyland
because he'll be in there for what five
seconds right Jesus they're everywhere
I feel so bad for the families at
Disneyland like there's two kinds of
people that go to Disneyland you have
the families and then out here in
California we grow these weird Disney
adults
and you know God bless them I don't know
where the money comes from but
it's going to Mouse ears and turkey legs
and they're having a damn good time
and they're just walking around enjoying
Disneyland then you have the families
and it's always the moms doing the hard
work right it's always the moms they've
been training for this all season long
they have like nine fanny packs this is
a military operation
they're barking out orders of their kids
Fastpass churro Dole Whip go go
where's Dad dad's always trailing by 20
yards
pushing a stroller with nothing in it
there's no beer anywhere really
because every
sundown
they're trying to get out of Disneyland
and that's when the Disney adults start
coming in and so you have this battle
the bastards between the two
it's just an army of strollers versus a
battalion of trust funds coming at them
and again it's just like watching the
families walk out of Disneyland here's
what I propose I think as you exit
Disneyland you should be able to take a
left and go to parking or take a right
and get a vasectomy right then and there
[Applause]
honey you get the car I got one more
ride I gotta go on real quick
and make it part of the fun you know let
goofy perform it
put a sign up Mr Toad Urology and
you get in the office you're waiting the
Seven Dwarfs March in
the dock gives you the anesthesia Here
Comes goofy in a smock a hook you're
done
Mickey's waving to you now we both talk
like this
and it's Disneyland so on your way out
of the office you get a picture of
yourself getting a vasectomy
[Music]
so that liberals and conservatives kind
of hate at the same time
over the same subject just for different
reasons like last year we got that Buzz
Lightyear movie and both sides hated it
conservatives thought that Buzz
Lightyear made every kid in America gay
not sure what they base it on but that's
what the belief was
and liberals were like where was Buzz
Lightyear on January 6th
[Laughter]
[Music]
but you can't hate Disney you can't they
own everything we've ever loved
like for instance for me a big Star Wars
fan we got Star Wars fans here there we
go
I love Star Wars favorite Star Wars
character sir who you got
John it's Jar Jar Binks
really
hey look I am not going to hate on jar
jar but if that's your first round pick
how's your fantasy team doing this year
so if that's
you drafted the kicker in the first
round
I'll give you a joke okay so it's not
George or who is it Luke Skywalker there
you go that's a that's a born and bred
hero he's in my top five I like Leia I
like Chewie who is microchips
um
but my favorite Star Wars character of
all time Yoda
love me some Yoda not the baby
we all remember the last joke not the
baby
I like OG Yoda I like Yoda and it's not
because Yoda's wise it's not because
Yoda is powerful I love Yoda because
Yoda's 900 years old
900. Yoda's a 900 year old man not one
sexual assault allegation against them
not one he's been on the Jedi Council
for 700
never a secretary
never a Christmas party
never a road gig in Jacksonville legal
she looked never happened once
[Applause]
you ladies imagine getting a Dam from
Yoda in the middle of the night
just says up you
Yoda's on the straight and narrow man he
never got tag hash two Mead
of all the jokes you're gonna see
tonight that was the hardest [__] one
to pull off
that
puppet
that's syntax is something special man
and I am not a Jedi
I do know this about Star Wars uh the
fans are spoiled
like you fans that are so spoiled
because you have 12 Movies you have a
new episode of ATV show every week and
you still find flaws you're like I don't
know that's Speeders bright pink really
is that what we're doing
why don't you take the DeLorean back to
my my era when I was a kid in the 90s
when we had to read new Star Wars
yeah and we actually had to read it not
like you Game of Thrones fans who claim
to read the books
Game of Thrones fans they love telling
their friends they read the books they
buy the books they put them on a nice
shelf and then they listen to the books
in audio form
you didn't read the books you had them
read to you like an infant
[Applause]
my niece and my nephews they're super
into Harry Potter
they love Harry Potter so much so that
this past Halloween when the Ellis
family went trick-or-treating together
we all had to go with Harry Potter
characters and guess who got to be the
person of Honor yeah my niece she asked
me the day before Halloween she's like
Uncle Mark we talked about it
and in my head I'm like [__] is this an
intervention is it
and she's like we want you to be hairy
and yeah it was so cute and I knew it
was going to break her heart because I
said yes and I'll and I'll do everything
I can to pull off Harry Potter but she's
seven she's expecting the kid from the
movies she's not expecting middle-aged
burned out
hasn't cast a spell in 30 years Harry
Potter
stewardess Gryffindor rope against a
High School varsity jacket
but Harry Potter I'll give a credit man
adults love that too and I think it kind
of still works like there's some things
that we all loved as kids that just
don't work when you're a grown-up He-Man
great example you would not find a
better fan of He-Man than I I was the
biggest T-man fan when I was five years
old other things I enjoyed when I was
five included eating my own boogers and
having my mom wipe my ass because I
don't know how to do it yet
but my buddy called me he's 45 years old
he called me a couple weeks ago he's
like man they're making a new He-Man
movie how exciting is that and I'm like
well I'm an adult so I
I just don't think it works especially
in modern times the name He-Man
it's a little pronoun specific don't you
think
maybe call it he maybe
them person
sometimes characters will just let you
down though like the biggest letdown for
me was Batman
and I'm not talking about the movies
like all the movies are cool but just
actually knowing the character this
happened a little while back there was a
there's an animated show in the Batman
Universe about the character Harley
Quinn and the writers put a joke in
there and about Batman they said Batman
was going down on Catwoman and water
Brothers nixed the joke
they said Batman doesn't do that
yeah apparently Batman is the DJ Khalid
of superheroes
[Applause]
he doesn't go South of the Border okay
and it's like their official quote was
good guys don't do that
and if that's true that means get the
hand basket because I'm going to hell
[Applause]
I'm telling you you ladies cheering
that's great but it's really better for
both parties okay because sex is fun but
that's where babies come from so I'm
nervous and when you're having sex
sometimes you open your eyes at the same
time it's like oh hey you're okay I'll
close first and
there's just weird rules to sex like
it's the most fun thing you could on
Earth yet you're a creep if you smile
during it
[Applause]
you know just let me do my thing you do
your thing give me the canary I'll go
down below and
and then you ladies can focus on what
you do well you can work on the acting
performance of your career
and I'm down there getting work done
because going down doesn't it's not like
a talent thing it's just a heart thing
it's just a gritty gutty
every word you associate with white
athletes that's what going down is
you know just try your best and just
never give up
[Music]
and that's why Batman's mopey all the
time because he can't please a woman
apparently the world's greatest
detective can't find the clitoris
so he's just at home with Alfred
watching Blue Bloods night after night
meanwhile Jokers out there Robin Banks
having fun eating ass getting things
done
[Applause]
[Music]
you know as you all let me talk more you
realize why I'm single
which I'm I not only do I love being
single I think all my married friends
actually love that I am single
because all the females that I'm friends
with that are married I'm their little
experiment
you know if they love trying to set me
up with somebody and my dude friends
they adore me because I'll get a text
like hey man what are you doing right
now and I'm like well it's 2 30. so I'm
watching ESPN then I'm gonna go take a
nap
and they're like can I come over
can I nap with you more
like every couple sometimes you just
need an outlet I'm your wingman come on
over hang out remember what it used to
be like
because I don't know if it's gonna
happen for Old Uncle Mark I don't
and I don't really care about it because
we all know that like person who they're
in a serious relationship they break up
and then they're just not themselves
until they meet somebody else like I
have a friend they broke up and then the
next week they met somebody new they're
already saying I love you they're
playing trips together that's not my
speed okay I break up with somebody I
need a good six seven years to really
think about what happens
you know where she went wrong
I do like the dating event though like
dating it's an event for me I get up for
it I get excited about it first day with
me awesome you have a great time on the
first date I have some funny stories I'm
Charming I can usually cover the bill
second day that's when it starts to go
downhill
second day you're like he really likes
Van Halen
third date you're like he fell asleep at
the table can I leave I don't know what
to do
yeah and um you know I think it just
doesn't make sense for me to settle down
now when we're so close to
interplanetary travel
you know who knows when it could happen
but if you think when we can just go
live on another planet if you think I'm
dragging some Earthling up there with me
no man I want to be like Star Trek I
want to live long prosper and Captain
Kirk some hot alien ass that's the dream
my mom is thrilled that I don't have
kids
so much so that I'm like a little
offended
because she'll say things to me that she
will not say to her other two kids my
sister has one kid great my brother's
got two kids awesome I got a dog and
she's like are you sure you're ready for
that responsibility
just like I just feel like we're past
the Golden Age with kids
like the 1600s that was
that was how you do it the 1600s you can
have there was no pressure about modern
society there was no worry about school
shootings or virtual reality you had one
roll back then don't talk to the cursed
goat
everybody had a farm there's fun animals
just that one googly-eyed one we think
it's a witch don't talk to that one
the Quaker Road guy said it put a curse
on us if you looked at it so don't do
that
but now man kids I just don't find a lot
of good reasons to have kids
I'm not sure one of the ones they used
to hear is oh I need to propagate the
species
eight billion of us on Earth if Earth
was a nightclub that fire marshall would
shut it down
had a buddy he's like oh I just kind of
wanted to kick because they're cute
if you think kids are cute you've only
seen the first 10 minutes of gremlins
the best though is one of my friends has
four kids and he's like I don't know man
I just wanted something to you know give
a legacy to me
I just want something to outlive me and
I'm like dude you wanted a turtle
all right Turtles are much cheaper kids
will eat you out of house and home a
turtle one head of lettuce keeps it
satisfied for like a decade
you want kids but you're on a budget
turtle
yeah and it's it's a funny situation my
family too because like currently
there's two single people left there's
me and my mom
okay but my mom is out there
she travels the world she meets
interesting people but sometimes it
happens where you don't expect it like
she started hanging out with a guy who
lives up the street
and we've had that house for 30 years
he's been there for 30 years we have
both been in that neighborhood for so
long when I was a kid I took his
daughter to a couple high school dances
yeah and remember boys going to pick up
your date so nerve-wracking because
you're in your suit you're sweaty you
ring the doorbell you know she's not
answering
she's got to do her Bell Beauty and the
Beast walk down the stairs
so it's the dad he just opens the door
and he's like you have her home by 10 30
young man I'm a kisser
so this past Thanksgiving I was home
and guess who came to pick my mom up
yep
oh I was waiting it was 3 30 p.m and I
was just sitting in a rocking chair
waiting
he Rings a doorbell I answer and he's
like hey Mark I'm here to take your mom
out and I'm like 10 15 [__]
you have no idea how weird it is to call
someone a [__] and have it maybe
be accurate
[Laughter]
[Music]
she was seeing this other guy too who
who has Netflix like and I don't know
what my mom does I think they're just
friends but I don't know if they Netflix
and chill where they Paramount plus and
snore whatever they do
is fine but she said he has Netflix and
when I tell you he has Netflix I mean he
still has Netflix send DVDs to his
mailbox
I [__] you not did anybody know that was
still an option on the table that used
to be the whole business model now it's
just the one cubicle in the corner
it's like well we can't fire Todd he's
the boss's kid just give him a bunch of
those envelopes to play with
and I don't long for that era I don't
long for the era of getting DVDs in the
mail I missed the previous era when the
whole family would Pile in the car
Friday night and you go to Blockbuster
video that was a big night
big big night in the Ellis family
because you drive out there and it was
so exciting going to the video store
with all this anticipation and you knew
you were leaving with your fourth choice
because we all have the same strategy
you go to the video store you start new
releases you go A to Z and then
everybody disperses to their favorite
section my sister tried to run a horror
movie oh that's gonna scare your little
brother my dad wanted an action movie
honey it's rated R Mark is trying to
rent Basic Instinct again that's not
gonna work
so then you just get in this debate and
it ends 30 minutes later with what you
know what [__] it just grab Sister Act
again and we'll all watch that
we went to Blockbuster once but it was
like three towns over so my Town
Williamsburg Virginia we didn't have
Blockbuster we had the local video store
video update which was actually better
than Blockbuster because we had all the
same sections they had but video update
also had the curtain
yeah the curry it was always way in the
back
and it was black with like glitter and
weird stains all over it
that was the current the wed of the
adult film section and you weren't
allowed back in there if you were under
18 they had a mirror so everybody could
see who was in there and 12 year old
Mark Ellis came up with a scheme yeah
four-person operation me my buddies Jack
Brian and Doug so Jack got a ride to my
house we rode bikes to Brian's and then
we rode bikes to Doug's Doug's dad was a
marine so Doug took this [__] seriously
he comes out of his house he's 12 years
old head to toe camo
he's like hey man I couldn't get the
sword but I got a knife and we're like
what the [__] are you talking about
so here's what I came up with my job was
to distract the front Court guy right
you know the guy who's always judging
you he's got his picks
that are sacred doesn't matter what
you're renting he's gonna say it's not
good enough
like oh 2001 A Space Odyssey Kubrick's
other Space movie
have you seen the moon landing
so my job is entertain That Guy Brian
Jack they were the lookout and then Doug
was the most crucial part of the
operation Doug GI Joe crawled back there
and he couldn't get back to the magical
land of Oz but he could reach his hand
around the corner and he could pull a
movie only problem was he couldn't see
what movie he was pulling
so first time we tried he pulled Edward
penis hands
so now we got to watch a movie about a
guy with five dicks on his hand
which ended up being one of my top 10
favorite film experiences of all time
because we put it on at my house where
we had all the good snacks and we're
watching it and this is like two in the
morning and my mom comes downstairs half
awake just to get a glass of water she
walks through the living room like oh I
love Winona Ryder good night guys
so then Doug pulled another one the next
week we got cocky and he pulled hot
Asian Invasion six
yeah do you know anything about that
franchise that's when it got good
that was there Fast Five
that's not the end of the mission you
have to go to another section and switch
the tapes out with something we're
allowed to rent so he goes to the family
section first movie he sees the
Adventures of Milo and Otis
if you remember that movie it's a dog
and a cat and they go across the country
together
it's a great journey
and the guy working there thinks we
can't wait to get home to see this
and the next guy that tries to rent hot
Asian Invasion six instead gets the
adorable journey of a dog and a cat
going across the country together
and it's just such a weird mind [__] to
thank all those guys that I came up with
that scheme with they have families
and me I just moved out out to L.A and I
and okay now but I mean there's a lot of
Misadventures you get into back in the
day and I used to work at the uh the
world famous comedy store I used to be
an employee there and you do whatever
they ask you to do you park the cars you
clean up the puke we're at the front
desk so I drank a lot and I remember I
got home one night and I was hammered
and it was my little studio apartment
right I've since added a whole bedroom
to the Empire
so I whenever you get home and you're
drunk you're some level of one of three
things you're either tired you're hungry
or you're horny
and you don't know which one you are all
the time sometimes you think you're one
and it turns out no you were something
else
so a couple weeks prior to this I had
met a sex worker
at a gentleman's establishment
if you're over 50 in this room I met a
hooker at a strip club
and so I got her number and she's like
we should hang out sometime and I'm like
oh we should hang out sometime
and so I got home from The Comedy Store
I'm hammered and I make two phone calls
and then I pass out
I called her and I called Pizza Hut
and then I fell asleep
so I woke up the next day I had a bunch
of missed calls
and then I got two texts that morning
one was from her and it said thanks for
the pizza [__]
and then the other one was from the
Pizza Hut guy and it said dude anytime
you need pizza you give me a call
[Applause]
laughs
nobody out pieces the Hut by out [__]
the hut that night
you get older and
what we originally thought right because
when you're a kid you think oh I'm gonna
grow up I'll meet somebody or get
married I'll have kids that's the end no
no I'm here to tell you if you're still
single and you're my age there's more to
life there's more phases than you were
taught I decided a new one that I never
knew existed nobody told me about this
but now I'm in the phase of my life a
lot of my married friends they're
getting divorced
my friends are coming back
if you love something set it free
if you feel bad for the family or
whatever but you're also excited right
I got my body back sweet
but you got to be careful that's not
really your friend anymore is it no no
looks like your friend but they've been
through some [__] you can't understand
so it's like you took your friend as you
knew them bury them in pet cemetery and
now they're back like hey what's up man
[Applause]
hey man you got any of those PlayStation
fives left I saw a tweet you got any
um I do sincerely want to thank you all
for coming out tonight you guys have
been a
a fantastic crowd
and really this was like this was the
exact scenario that me and every other
committee was envisioning when we were
in lockdown and we couldn't perform in
front of you all night after night and
you just think when am I going to get to
get back here because when the lockdown
started I actually was in Vegas and I
had to scramble to get a flight home so
when you're scrambling to get a flight
home what airline do you use
it's Southwest who the [__] said spirit
I need to go from Vegas to LA and I
don't want to go through Cairo to get
there
Spirit isn't an airline it's an escape
room
no you want to fly Southwest
so I flew Southwest I have money
and I think my letter was like gee and I
know they went that high and but I'm
sitting on the plane I'm in row 38
success
and I'll never forget as long as I live
like 15 rows ahead of me a guy sneezed
and for the first time in my life nobody
blessed him
not one of the three nuns sitting right
behind him blessed him
and it was weird it was like a good
sneeze too it was like that that old man
sneak that
like they're really sick or they just
found treasure
so he sneezed once nobody blessed and we
all got silent he sneezed again and we
murdered him he's dead
and that story warms my heart for two
reasons one I got to kill a guy
and two a couple months ago I got to go
back to Vegas for the first time since
the pandemic and I got to work there
it was awesome because Vegas was back
and people were gambling restaurants
were full and it was awesome and I was
reminded that there is a fantasy to
doing stand-up that is not the reality
there's a difference you have your
fantasy of what you think the job is and
then the reality of what the gig
actually is so the fantasy of stand up
is that you're gonna go on the road and
you're going to entertain audiences and
you're gonna make a bunch of beautiful
women laugh and then one of them is
going to come back to your hotel room
with you and you make love all night
long
hasn't happened yet
but I've only been doing this 17 years
so there's still time
the reality is you go on the road you
make a bunch of beautiful women laugh
and then you go back to your hotel room
alone and the sex is always happening
right next door
I've heard a lot of people have sex
and it's fun now
but back when I was a young comic it
freaked me out first time I heard it I
didn't know how to react because when I
was a kid I never heard my parents have
sex they Wrestled a lot never heard them
have sex
yeah
occasionally you see Dad take a leak in
the middle of the night why is he
wearing a cape you know what he's a
wrestler that's what I'm going with
so first time I was on the road and I
had it I was doing a gig somewhere in
the Midwest and like the painting on my
wall was vibrating and what do you do in
that situation do you call the front
desk and complain do you ride it out I
was like look I'm gonna give them 10
minutes and then I came so I'm like oh
boy
this escalated quickly um
so then you just wait another 10 minutes
and you bang on the wall hey I'm ready
to try again sorry about that
first timer
but now I'm a pro
I'm good best time I've ever heard other
people have sex
which is a great way to start a
conversation at a dinner party
best time I've heard other people have
sex San Diego Comic-Con 2018.
oh what a time it was and it was so
beautiful because it was nerds doing it
you know and like the misconception
about us nerds is that we don't have sex
that's not true we don't have a lot
but when we do you ever see a raccoon
eat a filet mignon
it's not going to last long but man
you'll remember that the rest of your
life
so I'm in my hotel room it's Saturday
night 3am I'm about to pass out I hear
the door next to me close and by this
point in my career I know the difference
between like one person and like an
excited couple
this was the latter so these people get
back to their room and the first thing
that turned me on that they might be
doing something
love making like
was not the sounds of passion first
thing I heard music
I heard the faint strains of a classic
John Williams theme song
these people got home
from being at Comic-Con all day eating
hot dogs reading comic books and they
said tonight's the night that we make
love to Jurassic Park
[Applause]
I got out of bed and opened a beer I was
like this is going to be fun
I'm yelling lines from the movie hold on
to your butts
use a condom life finds a way
and I knew it was getting good I knew
one of them was about to have the moment
because it was loud the music was
swelling on my nightstand I had a glass
of water and it started to Ripple
[Applause]
and I tell you that story not to
embarrass anybody no if you're in La for
the weekend if you're going on a trip
soon with your significant other I want
you to get in a hotel and have the
loudest most boisterous sex of your
entire life I just want you to realize
we can hear you too
so make it fun for everyone
right yell out something that's going to
make me laugh yeah yesi always works
go board game with it you sunk my
battleship
I'm a nurse whenever I climb actually I
say Chewie we're home
make it competitive and your winner
ladies don't do this thing you usually
do ladies don't do the oh God okay oh
God oh God God can't hear you I can't
make it fun for me dude do your favorite
fast food jingle right there
go political Epstein was murdered
make it historical oh right there right
there six temper tyrannos
my name is Mark Ellis thank you guys so
much
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
currently there's two single people it's
me and my mom
is that our cover
that was so [__] up that you did that
for my mom just like yeah
I think my dad's up in heaven like hey
don't talk about your mom being single
like that son Kill the Lights get rid of
the bed
foreign